if you were to look at julissa arcee's
life you might think she has had it all
she climbed the ranks of Wall Street's
most elite bank Goldman Sachs making
over 300 grand a year as a vice
president but she did it all get this as
an undocumented immigrant
jalisa RSA is here to tell us her story
she is now the director of development
at define America a nonprofit that helps
women and men just like her undocumented
immigrants and our own Bloomberg News
superstar who wrote a piece about her
for Bloomberg Businessweek max Abelson
one of my favs Chalisa we've had the
chance to read this extraordinary story
if you haven't out there get yourself
this as we get on the terminal and read
it but tell us give us the history well
I came here when I was 11 and I came
here originally on a tourist visa and my
visa expired and because I used the
tourist visa to come live here getting a
new one was likely to be impossible and
that wasn't a risk that my parents
wanted to take to be separated from me
so I became undocumented when I was 14
Texas passed a law in 2001 that allowed
me to go to college and I graduated from
the University of Texas at Austin in
2005 and but even though Texas said you
could go to college could you work no
but did you go to college but not pay
tuition and not being 48 give you some
sort of temporary documentation to go to
college no no they agreed to let you go
to college even though they knew you
were illegally in the country yes did
they give you a scholarship no I did get
I did get a private scholarship but I
did not get financial aid so even though
the law allows undocumented students to
go to college and pay in-state tuition
it does not allow it does not allow us
to receive financial aid how do you go
from college to Goldman I had an
internship at Goldman in 2004 through a
program called sponsors for educational
opportunities SEO and I did well during
the internship and so I was asked to
come back full-time um
and when I got this job offer I was
faced with a really difficult decision
my choices were to give up on my future
and then the sacrifices my parents made
and the sacrifices that I made would
seem pointless or my other choice was to
break the law and use fake people it's
such a gray area though isn't it because
the state of Texas knows in fact it
allows you to go college in the state so
it knows that you're there it's not
they're not doing anything about it so
they sort of tacitly allow you to be in
this country
why doesn't Washington make steps to to
change this to make it legal since
States already know what's happening and
don't do anything about it that is a
great question and when I ask myself all
the time I was gonna ask max okay so
hold on a second you intern at Goldman
now it's time to get a full-time job I
used to work at a bank
I remember they do background checks I
can remember stressing over those a
little bit you had to be worried how am
I gonna possibly get through this we
live a fake social security number I was
absolutely terrified um it was really
really scary filling out those documents
and knowing that I could get found out
at any minute and for what happened they
didn't actually check no III they
definitely check just I think you know
I'm not an expert on this but I believe
that what a background check checks for
is a criminal record which I don't have
um and now one and I think max you know
this better than I do that Goldman now
follows a different process right than
it did before no that's exactly right
now how'd you find that I mean this is
an extraordinary story this is what
movies are made about and I just love
the fact that it's a Goldman of all
places
how did you find this uh you know
sometimes stories take a really long
time julissa and I talked it was like
more than a year ago right for a story
that I wrote that that's out there about
young people on Wall Street and who had
their own nonprofits who are really
engaged in nonprofits as julissa is with
a send fun yeah and it was only a few
weeks or maybe a couple months ago now
where she emailed
right and she said I max you memory
there is something I didn't tell you
when we talked last time and I found out
about her story and we took it from
there so why is I mean this is a great
story and I recommend everyone go to
Bloomberg comm to check it out beyond
this the actual story of jalisa I'm sure
you've looked into the immigration
question on the whole the state of Texas
you know tacitly allows immigrants to be
there and operate in in our system the
state of New York does the same thing
the Titans of business at the top of the
labor period pyramid want immigrants do
these jobs at the bottom of the labor
pyramid we want immigrants to do these
jobs the country was built on
immigration question what's stopping us
well first of all don't be don't get
confused about Texas because although
Rick Perry signed into law a state bill
that allowed undocumented immigrants to
go to the University of Texas at
in-state tuition
thus allowing jalisa right you could go
to college because of that Rick Perry
also stood up on a stage just a couple
weeks ago and said if the US doesn't
secure the border Texas will so there
there's a lot of mixed things going on
now there it's not as if Texas is
incredibly eager to welcome document Lee
there is there's a big opposition to
this House bill 1403 that was what
allowed me to go to college and Greg
Abbott the new Texas governor has said
that he will veto that law so it that
law right now is at risk and there there
are thousands and thousands of students
who may not be able to finish their
college education if this law is
repealed
how did Goldman Sachs find out find out
that you were undocumented a did not
know she never she got married and got
her green that's right oh the whole
story I got it so you got married and at
any point while you were working there
the pressure the stress the secrecy of
it the fact that you lost that your
father who was living in Mexico and you
couldn't fly to go see him and you had a
super high-pressure job you didn't think
you wanted to tell anybody no I
absolutely wanted to tell someone but
the reason I didn't was for two reasons
one I think there is this there is a
stigma that what I did was wrong and
that what I that what I did was shameful
right and I was embarrassed by it so I
didn't I didn't even tell my closest
friends I remember once my friends took
a trip to Mexico on vacation and they
were like you should come you need to
come with us this will be so much fun
and I said I can't I have to work and
I'd be such a workaholic take a break
but I couldn't go because I couldn't
believe the country right I want to I
want to I want to quickly read a
statement because Goldman Sachs actually
did respond to the story Lloyd Blankfein
said wouldn't it be great if we could
give a home to more of the talented
young people who come to this country
for an education and want to apply their
energy that's what and skills to
supporting our economy and frankly it
makes sense if we're educating people in
this country why would we make them
leave after we give them the best
education in the world hold on that's
pretty extraordinary the same employed
did you ever meet him do you know him
I heard him speak a couple of times but
I never I never met him in person I
never had a conversation with him but I
was so humbled by his statement and I
was really shocked we are humbled by you
thank you so much a journey ELISA RSA
and the man who wrote the story our own
Max Abelson